ALAN ARCHULETA. CAN THESE
BABIES BACKER FORGES BRADFORD
CUT BY ADAM CORTEZ C. DALLEY
DIED DURAZO EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERZBERG WAY SO
HER TADO JONES CAN LONGER
LAYERED LLEVA THE MON MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
CELLO VOGUE PAM FORTUNE TINO
ROSSI RUBIO SKINNER STERN. I'M
BURKE WHITE HOUSE E. WINNER
WELL. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL IN
IN IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR SKINNER-
AFTER WHICH WE I SHOULD REMAIN
STANDING STILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE BY SENATOR STERN. YOUR
SCANNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
MAY YOU BE BLESSED WITH A
RESTLESS DISCOMFORT ABOUT EASY
ANSWERS HALF TRUTHS AND
SUPERFICIAL RELATIONSHIPS SO
THAT YOU MAY SEEK TRUTH BOLDLY
AND LOVE DEEP WITHIN YOUR HEART.
MAY YOU BE BLESSED WITH HOLY
ANGER AT INJUSTICE OPPRESSION
AND EXPLOITATION OF PEOPLE SO
THAT YOU MAY TIRELESSLY WORK
FOR JUSTICE FREEDOM AND PEACE
AMONG ALL PEOPLE. MAY YOU BE
BLESSED WITH THE GIFT OF TEARS
TO SHED WITH THOSE WHO SUFFER
FROM PAIN REJECTION STARVATION
OR THE LOSS OF ALL THE
TEACHERS. SO THAT YOU MAY REACH
OUT YOUR HAND TO COMFORT THEM
AND TRANSFORM THEIR PAIN INTO
JOY. MAY YOU BE BLESSED WITH
ENOUGH FOOLISHNESS TO BELIEVE
THAT YOU CAN REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS WORLD. SO
THAT YOU'RE ABLE WITH GRACE TO
DO WHAT OTHERS CLAIM CANNOT BE
DONE. MEMBERS GETTING THE
GALLERY PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. SIX ISRAEL. THE
SONG. MEMBERSHIP WE HAVE A
PRETTY FULL AGENDA SO LET'S GET
TO IT MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DOING READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
WILL BE DEEM READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WOULD BEING READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. MEMBERS WE HAVE
TIME FOR MOST IS A REAL
RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE
WEEK OF JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH.
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA WILL BE WAIVED FOR
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE THE HERE
AB FIFTY AND FORTY THREE ON
THURSDAY JULY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WHAT ELSE FOUR DAYS
NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE.
SENATOR SKINNER FOR PURPOSE- I
HAVE A MOTION. HI MOVED JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO AA BE WAIVED FOR
THE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO HEAR ASSEMBLY BILL%
ONE SIXTY ONE ON WEDNESDAY JULY
SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WITHOUT FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN THE
DAILY FILE. SENATOR NELSON THE
FIRST NIGHT I OBJECTED AND
REQUESTED A ROLL CALL VOTE
FIFTEEN SENATOR NELSON OBJECTS
WERE ASKING FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE SOONER SCANNERS LOOKING
FOR ALL RIGHT SENATOR NELSON'S
LOOKING FOR NO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA. I AT KINS. FIVE
EIGHT NO BACKER. HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM HI
CORTESE HI DALLY. NO DODD.
YOU'RE AWESOME HI EGGMAN I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ FIVE GROSS.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO FIVE HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I LIVE MY OWN.
I REQUIRE. MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A CHILL OF
BOTH. NO PAN ARCADE FORTUNE
TINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN I AM BERG HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI. HI WINNER I
WILL NO. MARCH TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS EIGHT CURRENT RULES ARE
SISTER WAVED. SENATOR HERTZBERG
HELLO OKAY. EARLIER. YEAH THIS
IS FOR FILE ITEM SIXTEEN.
YOU'RE ALL SET MR PRESIDENT.
EARLIER WE'RE NOT THERE YET ON
THE AGENDA. MEMBERS ARE MOVING
ON THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
FILE. THEM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE
FIFTY WITH AMENDMENTS FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE FORTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN NINETY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS THE GREEN
WILL BE DEAN RIGHT. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS- ALERT YOU'RE
PREPARED. I AM MISTER
PRESIDENT. OF FILE ITEM SIXTEEN
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF DIEGO
ARAMBULA AND JACK CLARK JUNIOR
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. MR AROUND A
LOT AS A FORMER TEACHER AND
PRINCIPAL CURRENTLY A PARTNER
AT TRANSCEND WHICH WORKS WITH
SCHOOL COMMUNITIES TO CREATE
EQUITABLE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS. MR CLARK IS A
PARTNER IN THE LITIGATION AND
SCHOOLS DEPARTMENTS AT THE
RIVERSIDE OFFICE OF BEST BEST
AND KRIEGER THEY WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY
NINETEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
SOONER OR TITLE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION
OF VEHICLE AND ON YOUR LAP AS
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
TRUSTEE. DIEGO IS HE DID IT AS
DEDICATED TO PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND HAS WORKED IN VARIOUS ROLES
OVER THE YEARS TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS. HE HAS SERVED AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER AND HAS
WORKED WITH MANY EDUCATORS
PRINCIPALS SUPERINTENDENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO ENSURE
CHILDREN HAVE THE BEST LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS AND ARE ABLE TO
THRIVE. AS SOMEONE WHO IS ALSO
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY HE
RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO THINK
OUTSIDE OF THE BOX WHEN IT
COMES TO EDUCATION ESPECIALLY
AMONG AMONG NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS AND IN. NONTRADITIONAL
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS. I KNOW
HE WILL HAVE VICKY ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT REALLY
ALL. CHILDREN AND STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I BOTH. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. HEARING SEEN NINE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE I'M SIXTEEN. ALAN
FIVE ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I
BASE. I BACKER R. FIVE FOR JUST.
HI BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM I
COURTESY HI DALLY. HI TODD HI
TORONTO HI ADMIN I. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROVE HI HURTS BERG
I WEAR SO I HER TADO HI JONES.
I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA
HI THE MON I REQUIRE. MELINDA'S
FIVE MEN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN I
WOULD SHOW UP BOTH. HI PAM HI
FOURTEEN TO NO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN I AM
BERG HI WHAT CASKEY HI WINNER.
I WILL. HI SIMILAR MOVES A CALL
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON THE FALL
ITEM SEVENTEEN CENTER ALERT
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF ANA ORTIZ MORE
FIT FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BOARD OF TRUSTEES OVER THE LAST
DECADE MISS SORTIES MORE PHOTOS
FOCUSED ON EDUCATION NONPROFIT
WORK INCLUDING SERVING ON THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
ON THE ADVISORY BOARD FOR
VISION OF HOW SHE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY
NINETEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT. IN
ONE SCENE NINE MEN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL ROLLING FILE I'M
SEVENTEEN. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS. FIVE EIGHT. BACKER I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM I COURTESY I DALLY. NO DOT
HI TORONTO BY ADMIN HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROSS. HERTZBERG I
WISH SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES
NO CAMCORDER I LAYERED I LLEVA
HI THE MOST I REQUIRE.
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. OCHO BOTH. PAN I
FOURTEEN TINA HI ROSS HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER. HI STERN I AM BERG I
WAKE OWSKI FIVE WINNER. I WILL
NO. SIMILAR MOVES A CALL NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FALL ITEM.
THIRTY THREE. SENATOR ALAN HE'S
NOT AT HIS DESK ARE YOU THERE
YES OKAY- PRINTER. FROM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY BY SENATOR
ALAN AND AFTER RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. THIS BILL IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE YOU MAY RECALL THAT
WHEN WE MADE THE DECISION TO
CONSOLIDATE ELECTIONS. A NUMBER
OF CITIES HAD TO BE A SITUATION
WHERE. AND THEY HAD IT THEY
CHANGE THE TERMS OF THEIR
COUNCIL MANAGER COUNCIL A
COUNCIL MEMBER DISTRICTS OF
TIME PERIOD THE- THE- THE TIME
THEY HAD AN OFFICE. AND OF
COURSE BY THEN WE DELAYED THE-
PRIMARY ELECTION NEXT YEAR- SO
AS TO ALLOW FOR THE
REDISTRICTING INFORMATION TO
COME IN. HI THIS IS LED TO A
SITUATION IN SEVERAL CITIES
WHERE THEIR TERMS WERE UP IN
APRIL- BUT WE DO NOT ELECTION
UNTIL JUNE SO THIS BILL SIMPLY.
ALLOWS THOSE FOLKS TO CARRY ON
AN OFFICE UNTIL THAT. ELECTION
THEY'RE VERY MINOR DAMAGE TAKEN
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I RESPECT
US RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IN NINETEEN NINE MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YES ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA FIVE
ATKINS I BASE HI BECKER FIVE
PORGES FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE A I
COURTESY. HI DALLY I DON I
TORONTO HI AIKMAN. GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI GROSS HI HURTS BERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO. JONES HI
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR I
LOVE MY OWN I MCGUIRE MELINDA'S
BY MEN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN FIVE
A TROUBLE BOTH. HI PAM FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I RUBIO
I SKINNER. HI STERN I AM BERG I
LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I WILL.
HI SINNER ALAMOS GOLD REMEMBERS
REMOVING ON TO SIMPLY THIRD
READING WE HAVE SOME FIVE ITEMS
SIX ITEMS ARE WE'LL DRESS FIRST
UP IS ITEM FORTY FOUR BALL ITEM
FORTY FOUR. LABOR SENATOR LIVE
ARE YOU PREPARED SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL AN ACT RELATING TO
STUDENT STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH
WEEK EARLIER BEFORE GEORGE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AC ARE SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH DESIGNATES A MATE TEN
THROUGH FOURTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS CALIFORNIA STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH WEEK. EVEN THOUGH
THAT WEAKENS PASS THIS IS STILL
AN IMPORTANT RESOLUTION THE
WEEK DRAWS ATTENTION TO
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
AND THE CRITICAL MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES PROVIDED BY OUR
SCHOOLS MEMBERS OF THE STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE FOR OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
MENTAL HEALTH MATTERS IN
SUPPORTING THE MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF OUR
STUDENTS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO HELP THEM GROW
THRIVE AND REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING CALIFORNIA STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH WEEK AND
INVOLVING THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING MENTAL WELLNESS FOR
ALL OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
MEMBERS I REQUEST I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SITE ON. NOON JINAN MENTORED
HER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS HI STATE.
FIVE BACKER ARI FORGES I
BRADFORD I CAN'T BUY A HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY I DON FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI LASER.
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH HI HURTS
BERG HI WHERE SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER FIVE
LAYERED. HI LLEVA. HI THE MON
FIVE MCGUIRE MELINDA'S FIVE MEN
HI NEWMAN I NELSON I WOULD SHOW
UP BOTH. HI TEN FIVE FORTINO
FIVE BROTH FIVE RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER I STERN I AM BERG HI
WHITE HOUSE E. FIVE WINNER I
WILL. HI SOONER LABOR MOVES A
CALL NOW MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX SENATOR STERN
YOU PREPARED HERE'S MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AN ACT RELATING RELATIVE TO THE
BASEL CONVENTION. STERN FOR
GEORGE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT A J.
R. FOUR WHICH CALLS FOR THE
UNITED STATES RATIFICATION OF
THE BASEL AGREEMENT A CRITICAL
STEP IN PROPERLY REGULATING THE
INTERNATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE A PLASTIC DUMPING ON
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES. THE BASEL
CONVENTION RESOLUTION ON THE
CONTROL OF TRANSBOUNDARY
MOVEMENTS OF HAZARDOUS WASTES
AND THEIR DISPOSAL WAS SIGNED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE BUT IS
NEVER ACTUALLY RATIFIED BY THE
UNITED STATES. RATIFYING THIS
AGREEMENT WILL SHOW THE U. S.
WOULD TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OUR ROLE IN THE PLASTICS CRISIS
IN THAT WERE WILLING TO WORK
TOWARDS SOLUTIONS WE KNOW THAT
MANY MEMBERS IN THIS THIS
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING SENATORS
FROM SANTA MONICA AND FREMONT
HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD ON THESE
ISSUES BUT- THIS IS ALSO AN
INTERNATIONAL ISSUE WHERE.
PLASTIC IS FLOATING THE SIZE OF
TEXAS AND THE PACIFIC OCEAN
THERE'S AN ISLAND AND IT'S
IMPACTING CLUTCHES OCEAN LIFE
BUT MATERNITY HEALTH AND HEALTH
CARE THROUGHOUT OUR REGION
INCLUDING JAPAN THE PHILIPPINES
AUSTRALIA PERU ALL THE WAY THE
UNITED STATES NO ONE IS SPARED.
THE UNITED STATES IS NOW ONE OF
ONLY A FEW COUNTRIES THAT FAIL
TO RATIFY THIS VITAL
MULTINATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
AGREEMENT. TO PROTECT
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES FROM THE
EXPORT AND DUMPING OF WASTE
FROM OUR RICHER INDUSTRIALIZED
COUNTRIES. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THE BASEL CONVENTION WAS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE MIXED AND
CONTAMINATED PLASTIC WASTE
SHIPMENTS WITHIN ITS CONTROL
PROCEDURE. YES THE PROBLEM OF
PLASTIC WASTE COLLECTED FOR
RECYCLING INDUSTRIALIZED
NATIONS AND SENT TO HIGHLY
POLLUTING WRIST RECYCLING
OPERATIONS IN DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES. IN THESE LOCATIONS
THE PLASTIC WASTE IS OFTEN
DUMPED AND BURNED RED AND
SAFELY RECYCLE. AS OF JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE SUCH
EXPORTS REQUIRE THE
NOTIFICATION AND CONSENT OF
RECEIVING COUNTRIES PRIOR TO
EXPORT. HOWEVER THE UNITED
STATES NOT BEING ABOUT THE
PARTY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
LEGALLY EXPORT WAYS WHICH ARE
ILLEGAL FOR THE IMPORTING
COUNTRY TO RECEIVE LEADING TO
ILLEGAL TRAFFIC SEIZURES
LAWSUITS AND WASTE REPATRIATION
OFFENSE. AJ ARE FOR URGES THE
BY DEMONSTRATION TO ACT
IMMEDIATELY TO RATIFY THE BASEL
CONVENTION WHICH ADDRESSES THE
GROWING CONCERN ABOUT THIS
CRISIS ALL THE SCIENTIFIC DATA
SHOWS THAT PLASTIC WASTE POSES
AN EXISTENTIAL. THREAT NOT JUST
TO THE PLANET BUT TO EACH OTHER
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IN NINETEEN NINE MONTH
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA HI AT TENS I
BASICS. BACKER. FIVE FORTUS HI
BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DOLLY. DODD HI
THERE ASA HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WEAR SO. FIVE HER
TADO. HI JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED BY LABOR I LIVE MY OWN
HI MCGUIRE MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN FIVE A SHOW
OF BOTH. PAM I FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN I AM BERG HI WHAT CASKEY
HI WEINER I WILL HI. SINNERS
TURN MOVE THE CALL. NON MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM.
FIFTY NINE. SENATOR CAFIERO.
I'M SORRY MR FIFTY FIVE I'M
SORRY SENATOR ALSO. SPONSORED
PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALDERONE AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES SENATOR ALSO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SIMPLY
BILL TWO EIGHTY NINE SEEKS TO
ENSURE FAIRNESS IN SCHOOL
DISTRICT MERIT SYSTEM ELECTIONS
EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES THE ODD
ADOPTION AND REMOVAL OF SCHOOL
MERIT SYSTEMS BY A MAJORITY
VOTE OF CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
THIS BILL WILL CODIFY EQUITY
FOR THESE EMPLOYEES DURING
MERIT SYSTEM ELECTIONS AND ADDS
IMPORTANTOVERSIGHT TO THE
ELECTION PROCESS. ISRAEL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WILL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING THREE NINE MONTHS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOLLOW FIFTY FIVE. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI AT KENS FIVE FACE
I BACKER HI FORGES. BRADFORD HI
CUT BY ADAM I CORTESE HI DOLLY.
DODD HI THERE ALSO HI ADNAN HI
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATE HIGH
GROWTH HIGH HURTS BERG HI WHERE
SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA I
LIVE ALONE HI WIRE. MELINDA'S
HI MILLION FIVE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF BOTH. PAN
I FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN I AM
BERG I WAKE OWSKI I WINNER. I
WELL I. SENATOR ALSO MOVES A
CALL NOW MEMBERS REMOVAL ON THE
FALL ITEM FIFTY NINE SENATOR
CAFIERO ARE YOU READY HE IS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN
ACT RELATING TO CONTRACTORS
INNER COPIER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
FIVE SIXTY NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. THIS
BILL RAISES THE MAXIMUM CAP ON
CIVIL PENALTY FEES FOR
CONTRACTORS WHO VIOLATE
CONTRACTOR LAW. ON AVERAGE ONLY
ABOUT 3% OF CONTRACTORS VIOLATE
THE CONTRACTOR LINER SUBJECT TO
CIVIL PENALTY FEES EACH YEAR.
BUT FOR THE FEW BAD ACTORS THAT
EXIST CIVIL PENALTY FEES ARE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO DETER
VIOLATING A LAW HOWEVER THE
CURRENT FEE CAPS ARE DECADES
OUT OF DATE FOR MOST VIOLATIONS
OF CONTRACTORS LAW THE MAXIMUM
FEE THAT THE STATE CONTRACTORS
LICENSE BOARD. CAN FIND A
CONTRACTOR IS FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHICH WAS SET OVER
SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO FOR
SPECIFIC VIOLATIONS CONSIDERED
MUCH MORE EGREGIOUS CONTRACTORS
CAN BE FINED UP TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THIS
VIOLATION SPECIFIC MAXIMUM WAS
ESTABLISHED TWENTY NINE YEARS
AGO. IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO
ADDITIONALLY WHEN A CONTRACTOR
APPEAL THE CITATION IT NOW
COSTS THE CSL BE AT LEAST TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO DEFEND IT
IN COURT. PLUS THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN EXPENSES FROM THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS. AB FIVE SIXTY NINE
SOLVES THESE BY RAISING THE
CAPS ON CIVIL PENALTY FEES TO
BRING THEM IN LINE WITH THE
CONCERN CURRENT CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX FOR MOST VIOLATIONS OF
CONTRACTORS LAW THE FEES WILL
BE INCREASED TO A MAXIMUM OF
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND FOR
MORE EGREGIOUS VIOLATIONS THE
FEE WILL BE INCREASED TO UP TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS
MEASURE ALSO ALLOWS THE CSL BE
TO ISSUE AN ADMONISHMENT LETTER.
WHEN EDUCATION- PROOF OF
COMPLIANCE IS DETERMINED TO BE
A BETTER APPROACH THAN A
CITATION SO THEY'RE THEY'RE THE
FEET THE FINES WILL GO UP BUT
THERE'S ALSO A WAY TO BE ABLE%
TO GET A LETTER OF COMPLIANCE-
AND- MANAGEMENT LETTER WHICH-
WILL GUARANTEE COMPLIANCE AS
WELL. A. B. FIVE SIXTY NINE
WILL HELP OFFSET THE COSTS
FACED BY THE CSL BE IN
DEFENDING CITATIONS AGAINST BAD
ACTORS AND ENSURE THE CIVIL
PENALTY FEES REMAIN A VIABLE
DETERRENT TO VIOLATING THE LAW.
THIS COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
ALLOW THE CSL BE TO CONTINUE
EFFECTIVELY REGULATING THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BELL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
SUPPORT AND HAS NO NO VOTES AND
THANKFULLY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR HERE I WROTE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. NINETY
NINE MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS HI BABY. HI BECKER
HI FORGES HI BRADFORD I HAVE A
I COURTESY HI DALLY. I DON HI
TORONTO. ADMIN HI PLEASE- FIVE
GONZALEZ HI GROSS HI HURTS BERG
I WEAR SO. HI HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER HI LAYERED HI
LLEVA BY THE MON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S BY MEN HI NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN I A CHILL OF BOTH. PAN
FIVE FOURTEEN TINA I ROTH IRA
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN I AM
BERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKIING FIVE
WINNER I WILL. HI. SENATOR
CAFIERO MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FALL
ITEM. SIXTY THREE. SENATOR HER
TROUT- SHE IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERONE AN ACT
RELATING TO CAL WORKS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY VERA TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. CENTRE
HER TADO THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT A
B. ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN CALDERON. THIS
BILL EXTENDS THE DECENNIAL
CENSUS INCOME EXEMPTION FOR CAL
WORKS RECIPIENTS AND REQUIRES
THAT THE EXEMPTION BE
RETROACTIVE AS A RESULT OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
TEMPORARY CENSUS EMPLOYMENT HAS
EXTENDED INTO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- THE- FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES HAS ENCOURAGED STATES
TO DISREGARD THIS INCOME IN THE
CALCULATION OF ELIGIBILITY FOR
PROGRAMS SUCH AS CAL WORKS. A.
B. ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR LINES
WITH THIS RECOMMENDATION
INSURERS AT CAL WORKS RECIPIENT
CAN CONTINUE CENSUS EFFORTS
WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING C. NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON A V. TEN OH FOUR. ALAN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BAIT HI
BECKER. I PORCHES. BRADFORD I.
KERR BY ADAM I CORTEZ I DOUBT.
I DONT HI TORONTO. EGGMAN HI
GLAZER FIVE ALLAH'S EYE GROWTH.
HI HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI
HER TADO HI JONES I CAN'T
MONITOR I LAYERED I LABOR HI
THE MON HI MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH. PAM
FIVE FOURTEEN TINO I BROUGHT HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER FIVE STERN HI
AM BERG. HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL HI. SINNER HER
TADO MOVES A CALL NOW MEMBERS
REMEMBER GOING DOWN TO FALL
ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. INNER PORN
TEEN ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
I'M WITH THAT I DON'T. HE IS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
STAKE CLAIMS IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THERE FORD AND
CARTER URGES THAT THEY'RE OUT
SICK FOR TWO MEDIALLY.
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- EIGHTY
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE AS AN
EMERGENCY MEASURE TO
APPROPRIATE FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD FOR THE
PAYMENT OF FIVE STATE CLAIMS
RELATED TO A RONI'S
CONVICTIONS. IN EACH OF THESE
CASES THE COURT SET ASIDE THE
CONVICTIONS AND MADE A FINDING
OF FACTUAL INNOCENCE THE BOARD
HAS APPROVED THE CLAIMS AND
RECOMMENDS AN APPROPRIATION TO
COVER THESE CLAIMS. THE BILL%
ALSO APPROPRIATES AND LEVIN
HUNDRED FORTY SIX DOLLARS TO
PAY- THE THREE CLAIMS ACCEPTED
BY THE GOVERNMENT CLAIMS
PROGRAM. TO REISSUE CHECKS THAT
WERE NEVER CASHED- SP FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS HAD
ZERO NO VOTES IN EITHER HOUSE
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
OF. UNITY NINE MOUNT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT
FIVE BACKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
CORTEZ THREE HI DOLLY. HI DOT
HI TORONTO. ADMIN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS HI HERZ BERG
I WAS SO. HER TADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER HI LAYERED HI LLEVA
HI THE MON HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN. HI NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN HI A TELEPHONE. PAM
HI FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE. I WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. FIVE THE- WAY SO
I CAN REPORT TO YOU KNOW MOVE
THE CALL MEMBER TO CONCLUDE
THIS IN THE THIRD READING NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. DON'T. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS LITTLE CHANGE IN PLANS
ARE GOING TO GO NOW TO. MANY
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO BE MADE AT
THIS TIME. SINNER CORTESE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THE
LIVER PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE WILL MEET
IN ROOM FOUR TWO OH THREE A
TWENTY MINUTES AFTER THE END OF
THE SESSION THANK YOU. LABOUR
WILL MEET IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE AT THE CONCLUSION OF
SECTION. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT SOONER
OR SO. YEAH WE HAVE ENERGY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UTILITIES
COMMITTEE MEETING THE SENATE
CHAMBERS UPON ADJOURNMENT.
UNTIL THE END OF JUNE- AND
UTILITIES WILL BE MEETING AND
THE CHAMBER AT THE CONCLUSION
OF SECTION. NOW MEMBERS WERE
GONNA RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RATHER RESOLUTIONS THIS WOULD
BE THE PROPER TIME FOR ANY
ADJOURN IN MEMORY DO WE HAVE
ANY- JOURNEY MEMORIES AT THIS
POINT. SOONER OR LATER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY TODAY FOR THE
HONORABLE MICHAEL GRAVELLE OF
FORMER UNITED STATES SENATOR
FROM ALASKA WHO WAS A RESIDENT
OF MY DISTRICT WHO PASSED AWAY
AT THE AGE OF NINETY ONE. HE
WAS A LIFELONG PUBLIC SERVICE
AS A SERVANT AND DEFENDER OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE WHO COURAGEOUSLY
ADVOCATED FOR EQUAL RIGHTS
THROWN HIS LONG AND STORIED
CAREER. INSPIRED MANY INCLUDING
MYSELF HE WAS A CANDIDATE FOR
VICE PRESIDENT AT THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO THE DEMOCRATIC.
NATIONAL CONVENTION WHEN I WAS
A VERY YOUNG DELEGATE HE HAD
WRITTEN A BOOK ABOUT HIS
THOUGHTS ON THE FUTURE OF
AMERICA AT THE TIME IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THAT
CONVENTION. HE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN SPRINGFIELD
MASSACHUSETTS HE SERVED IN THE
ARMY'S COMMUNICATION
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE. MANY WENT
ON TO ATTEND COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY. AND AFTER EARNING
HIS B. S. IN ECONOMICS HE MOVED
TO ALASKA IN THE LATE NINETEEN
FIFTIES WERE ENTERED POLITICS.
HE SERVED IN THE ALASKA HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE TO SIXTY
SEVEN. WHEN HE BECAME SPEAKER
OF THE ALASKA HOUSE HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE U. S. SENATE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND SERVED
TWO FULL TERMS. HE ALWAYS
REMAINED TRUE TO ITS MISSION OF
GUARANTEEING EQUAL RIGHTS AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. HIS TRACK
RECORD DISPLACES FERVENT
DEVOTION TO ENSURING LGBTQ
EQUALITY WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY AS WELL AS FIRM
OPPOSITION TO THE WAR ON DRUGS
CITING THE DISPROPORTIONATE
DAMAGE TO INNER CITY
COMMUNITIES. HIS EFFORTS IN
CONGRESS WERE CRITICAL TO
SECURING BIPARTISAN COMPROMISES
THAT SET ASIDE MILLIONS OF
ACRES FOR NATIONAL PARKS
WILDLIFE REFUGES AND OTHER
PROTECTED AREAS IN ALASKA AND
ACROSS THE NATION. AS A
TESTAMENT TO HIS BOLDNESS HE
BECAME NATIONALLY KNOWN FOR HIS
ANTI WAR STANCES FAMOUSLY
LEADING A ONE MAN FILIBUSTER TO
PROTEST THE VIETNAM ERA DRAFT
AND READ INTO THE CONGRESSIONAL
RECORD MORE THAN FOUR THOUSAND
PAGES OF THE PENTAGON PAPERS.
HE LATER LAUNCHED HIS TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IS A
VOCAL CRITIC OF THE IRAQ WAR.
NO MEMORY OF THE FORMER SENATOR
WOULD BE COMPLETE WITHOUT
RECOGNIZING THE TREMENDOUS
ACHIEVEMENTS OF HIS WIFE
WHITNEY STEWART GRAVEL WHO WAS
A PASSIONATE AND INDEPENDENT
LEADER IN HER OWN RIGHT
FIGHTING FOR GENDER EQUALITY
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND
DEMOCRATIC VALUES. MIGHT COULD
SURVIVE BY HIS WIFE WHITNEY
GRAVELLE TWO CHILDREN MARTIN
ANTHONY GRAVELLE AND WHEN
DENISE MOTOR TWO SISTERS MARIE
LOMBARDI AND SISTER MARGUERITE
GRAVELLE FOUR GRANDCHILDREN AND
A GREAT GRANDSON TODAY WE
RECOGNIZE THE FORMER SENATOR
FOR HIS LIFE'S WORK- WHICH
SERVES TO BENEFIT THE LIVES OF
MILLION- I REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYER ROW ASKED
THAT YOU BRING THE NAMES SO WE
CAN GO TO THE DESK SO IT CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED AND WE-
COMMEND THE SENATOR FOR HIS
GREAT WORK. OUR NEXT SENATOR
MELINDA IS FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
EIGHT I'M MAKING A MOTION TO
WITHDRAW AS SIERRA FIVE.
PERCENT GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
CAN YOU BROUGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
FULL AN ROBUST DEBATE. IT HAS
BEEN FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE DAYS DOWN MEMBER SINCE THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED A TATE OF
EMERGENCY FOR COVERT AND SHUT
DOWN THE STATE. CALIFORNIA HAS
LOST ROUGHLY THREE MILLION JOBS
DUE TO BUSINESS CLOSURES AGAIN
WE'VE ONLY RECOVERED ABOUT HALF
OF THEM. ON JULY FOURTEENTH. OF
LAST YEAR. THERE WAS A TOTAL OF
FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT NEW CASES
REPORTED IN LA COUNTY YESTERDAY.
THERE WERE ONLY FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN POSITIVE CASES
REPORTED THAT'S OUT OF TEN
MILLION PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
THAT COUNTY WE'VE COME VERY FAR
EVERYONE WHO WANTS A VACCINE
CAN GET ONE. 58% OF
CALIFORNIANS ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED AND THERE IS NO
LONGER A NEED TO MAINTAIN THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY I ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. SENATOR HERTZBERG
MEASURES MAJORITY LEADER
ASTRONOVA THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA'S IS ASKING FOR YES
VOTE THE MAJORITY LEADERS
ASKING FOR NO VOTE BANK SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA- NO ATKINS NO FACE HI
BACKER NO FOR AGES HI BRADFORD
NO BY ADAM NO DON'T CORTEZ. NO
DALLY. HI TODD. NO THERE ARE SO.
A COMMON NO GLAZER. NO GONZALEZ
NO GROWTH HI HURTS WORK. NO WAY
SO NO HER TADO NO JONES HI
CAMCORDER. NO LAYERED NO LLEVA.
NO THE MON NO MCGUIRE NO
MELINDA'S I MEN. NO NEWMAN NO
NIELSEN. HI A CHILL OF BOTH HI
TAM. NO FOURTEEN TO NO NO ROTH
NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER NO STERN
NO I'M BURKE NO BY CAL SKI NO
WINNER. NO WILL HI. THIS OUR
OUR USE MAIL. I MEAN HI THESE
NINE NOS TWENTY NINE THE
MEASURE FAILS THE MOTION FAILS.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE.
WHEN FOR A FEW MEMBERS COME
BACK TO THE FLOOR. SENATOR
GLAZER FOR WHAT PURPOSE. THE
CONDITION OF THE FILE. THE
NUMBERS I WANT TO SHARE THE SAD
NEWS THAT- A MEMBER OF THE
SENATE THAT SENATE EXETER
THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT TIME.
THANK YOU.
OUR MEMBERS WERE
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
OUR OUTSTANDING ITEMS. MOUNT
SECTOR WE'RE GONNA START WITH
FALL ITEM EIGHTEEN GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT PLEASE CALL. I'M
SORRY FILE I'M SIXTEEN I'M
SORRY PLEASE CALL AFTER MEMBERS.
GLAZER I. MCGUIRE HI I. HIGHS
FORTY NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM SEVENTEEN. IN A
SECTOR PLEASE LOOK TO CALL.
BAYTEX FOR JUST. GLAZER I GROVE.
CHOIR I. NIELSEN OCHO A BUG.
ARE THESE THIRTY YOU WANNA
KNOWS FOR THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM THIRTY THREE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. ADMIN I GLAZER I. HER
TADO I. MCGUIRE HI. HIGHS FORTY
MILLS ZERO THE SIMILE MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED NOW MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM FORTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL AFTER MEMBERS. GLAZER I.
MCGUIRE I. HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING
ON THE FILE ITEM FORTY SIX MIN
OBJECTOR CALL AFTER MEMBERS.
ALAN I BAYTEX. DALLY GROVE.
JONES MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. A
CHILL ABOUT. FIVE THIRTY FOUR
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM FIFTY
FIVE. M. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THAT FOR MEMBERS. ALAN I PORGES.
DALLY. MCGUIRE I. BUT SHOWBOAT
HI. ARE YOU THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM
FIFTY NINE. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS.
ALAN HI. DURAZO A SHOW ABOUT. I.
MARCH THIRTY NINE KNOWS IT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. AND NOW
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM SIXTY
THREE. MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OUR AFTER MEMBERS. ALAN I
FOR JUST WHAT THERE ARE SO.
MELINDA'S. A SHOW ABOUT. SIXTY
HI. PRICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ALL RIGHT. SHE SAID HER BORDERS.
PORGESI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
THAT IS ON THEIR- ALL RIGHTS
THERE EIGHT KNOWS ON THE
MEASURE MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE. ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT. PLEASE CALL THAT TO
MEMBER. ALAN I DURAZO. BUT SHOW
A BUG I. FIVE THIRTY NINE KNOWS
IT ZERO ON THE URGENCY AUGUST
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO ON THE
MEASURE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON AND BACK
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE. IT IS THERE
ANY MEMBER DESIRING THEM REMOVE
ANY ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATOR RUBIO THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT ON RUSSIANS
RESERVATIONS PLEASE PULL FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
TWELVE ANYONE FROM SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES
OF CHAPTER NOT AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU REALLY NOTE SO
NOTE. SENATOR HUESO. THE
REQUEST TO THE AUTHORIZED TO
REMOVE. ITEM ONE FIFTEEN A. B.
SIX THREE SIX. TO BE PULLED
FROM CONSENT THANK YOU. REALLY
KNOWS WHAT OUR MEMBERS. BUT I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX THIRTY THREE TEN SEVENTY
NINE ELEVEN FORTY THREE FIFTEEN
NINETY ONE SEVEN TWENTY SIX
FOUR EIGHTY TWO FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE FOR AN ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
NINETEEN AS ON THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTIONS. FIFTY NINE SEVENTY
TWO EIGHTY THREE AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY.
HOME SECRETARYPLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA. HI AT KENS
FIVE EIGHT HI BECKER HI PORGES
I BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
PROTESTING HI DALLY I DONT. I
THEY'RE ALSO. AIKMAN HI GLAZER.
FIVE DOLLARS HI GROSS HI HURTS
BERG. WEST SO HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA HI THE MON. HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MEN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF OAK HI PAM.
HI FOURTEEN TINA. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI STERN I AM
BERG HI BY KELSEY HI WINNER. I
WILL HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
MILLS ZERO ON THE MEASURE ALL
EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
GLAZER WHAT PURPOSE. THE
CONDITION OF THE FILES
PRESIDENT. BERNIE. FOR YOUR
CENTER- MEMBERS AT I WANTED TO
SHARE THE SAD NEWS THAT A-
SENATOR FROM THIS BODY SENATOR
DICK RANNEY PASSED AWAY THIS
PAST WEEKEND. I REPRESENTED
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN THE
SENATE I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE PRO TEM'S
OFFICE IN THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER. ON A MOMENT TO AND OUR
FUTURE WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE THIS VERY
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZIER. MEMBERS OF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ACTIONS THE DEATHS IS
COOLER. MR PRESIDENT THANKS SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES THANK YOU OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS GOING TO
BE THIS THURSDAY JULY EIGHTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY.
AT WHICH TIME AN ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED. WE WILL
RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT NINE
A. M.